[Music]
all right
welcome to Avatar frontiers of Pandora a
first person action adventure game that
invites you to explore the engaging
world of Avatar in an immersive open
World experience
I'm Dede deanfeld game director and I'm
excited to reveal what's waiting for you
on Pandora
area of our game begins when the RDA
expands their operations to the Western
frontier
John Mercer one of the leaders of the
RDA abducts you and other Navi children
from your home to teach you the ways of
humans hoping to mold you and Turn you
against your own people
but his plan is interrupted by the
battle of the Hallelujah mountains and
you are put into emergency cryosleep
when you awaken 15 years later you are a
stranger in your birthplace knowing the
dangers posed by the RDA you set out to
take them down and look to secure the
help of other Navi Clans
initially you're perceived as an
outsider so you have to reconnect with
your lost Navi Heritage to gain their
trust
on your adventure you'll find your own
path as you discover what it means to be
Navi you'll explore new regions of
Pandora each with their own unique
biomes
the king Law Forest is a lush rainforest
brimming with life and dense vegetation
in the shade of awe-inspiring floating
mountains
this is the home of the Arana hay a clan
of peaceful Weavers who will guide you
on your first hunt and on your first
flight
will show you the way to The Rookery
where you can bond for life with your
very own ecrom
the ikran is a devoted companion that
you can name feed and customize
experiment with acrobatics and feel a
rush of adrenaline as you dive from the
sky and explore the open world of
Pandora from the air if you travel North
you'll get to the upper Plains
an expansive grassland filled with
contrasts and open views as far as the
eye can see
the nomadic seswa Clan live here in
symbiosis with gigantic beasts called
sakuru
earn the Clan's trust and they will
teach you the art of writing dire horses
and further west the mysterious clouded
Forest
were hidden in the Mist
nothing is as it seems
here is the cafeteria a clan of healers
with their own dark reasons to stay
hidden
operations are threatening the valley of
Pandora
they build facilities of all Sciences to
exploit resources at any cost spreading
devastating pollution
in the process animals are hurt and
poached
you'll need to stop the RDA from
ravaging your home and when you are
ready you will take the fight to them
as a child of Two Worlds you can learn
to master multiple combat Styles your
powerful instincts allow you to get an
overview of the battlefield Mark your
enemies and identify weak points
traditional Navi weapons are versatile
and precise you can use the Longbow to
hit long range targets or the staff's
link to set up traps
for a more explosive approach you can
leverage your human training and go for
the blast of an assault rifle a shotgun
or go bigger with the occasional rocket
launcher
foot you can also rely on your
Incredible strength to take down amp
units above the clouds your ikron will
help you in aerial combat against the
RDA
destroying RDA facilities will have a
tangible impact on your world
with the pollution removed Pandora heals
you'll be able to harvest the best
quality material again and craft better
gear and weapons
you will also find ingredients to cook
and make meals to get stronger
as you keep discovering what it truly
means to become Navi you'll improve your
skills by connecting to Ay through the
tarshu plant and learn from the memories
of your ancestors skill upgrades can
improve many aspects of your character
such as your natural agility to move
through the world your stealth approach
when hunting or fighting or the handling
of your weapons and mounts
Avatar frontiers of Pandora is a
captivating action-adventure game
designed to maximize the power of new
gen consoles and PC you will be able to
play the full story campaign in single
player or with a friend online in
two-player Co-op
we invite you to explore this world of
wonder
come Navi
take down the RDA to protect Dora
[Music]
thank you